هذه المهمة هي في الواقع أجيال
في طور التكوين تعود إلى علاقة
بين وكالة ناسا والفرنسيين حتى الثمانينيات
في أن تصبح مهووسًا حقًا بكيفية
قياس المياه السطحية
للأرض وتضاريس المحيط وهذا هو ما
تُعد طبوغرافيا المحيطات السطحية لمياه سوات
حالة-  من أحدث الأقمار الصناعية التي ستكون
قادرة على قياس أه مستويات سطح البحر بدقة
حول العالم ذات قيمة كبيرة عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالبناء والتكيف
في عصر ارتفاع مستوى سطح البحر أيضًا الأنهار
التي لم يتم قياسها قبل
ألاسكا على سبيل المثال لديها مليون ميل
من الأنهار ولكن 10 في
المائة منها فقط لديها مقاييس ولكن الآن
سيتم قياسها جميعًا وفي عصر
عدم اليقين المتزايد بشأن دورة المياه ،
رأينا هذا مع حالات الجفاف الهائلة التي
لا توجد مياه كافية في بعض الأماكن كثيرًا جدًا
في  البعض الآخر الفيضانات في باكستان
هذه الأداة البيانات الدولية
المتاحة للجميع ستكون ذات قيمة كبيرة للمضي قدمًا
على الأقل حتى تجد جميع
المركبات الفضائية الأخرى التابعة لناسا كوكبًا آخر به
الماء ولكن ربما يكون من الحكمة
الانتباه إلى الأشياء التي لدينا الآن هذه
الأيام وخاصة يوم العلم
بيل وير سي إن إن نيويورك